that's a big day on the las vegas strip
some of the strip's biggest shows are
going to be back in action for the first
time in
months this is at mgm resorts they're
bringing back seven shows up and down
the las vegas strip tonight
one of those fantasy at the luxor and
joining us right now from the luxor this
morning mariah riviera who managed to
wake up this early we appreciate that
you're one of the cast members of
fantasy mariah thanks for joining us
this morning we appreciate it
yes sir yes thank you for having us
happy to be here
all right so um we were talking before
we started here about
this the struggles and the challenges
for the entertainers all across las
vegas for the last several months
how exciting is it just to be back on
stage again
it is so exciting we've been waiting
seven months patiently you know on our
couches waiting for the call
yeah we're so so excited so fortunate to
work for uh an amazing company and we
just can't wait to be back on stage
so we we've talked to a couple other
shows on the strip and they've talked
about the changes they've made to their
routines
uh to get back in action ever you know
and just to make sure it's safe for
everybody
what changes are in place over at
fantasy
yet we're following all cdc guidelines
we're wearing masks we're socially
distancing we have to stay six feet
apart from all the dancers
we're in a brand new theater which gives
us lots of space and stage so our
audience will be further back
but we have a lot of exciting changes
that we've made a lot of cameras
different things but
projections so we're really really
excited for our audience to see our new
show
plenty of elbow room very important
especially what else can fans
expect to see us there as they're
heading over to see the show you kind of
address this a little bit there but i
imagine you've had to make some tweaks
to what your
you guys were used to doing on stage for
so long
yes we've made a few tweaks but we've
had an amazing show for 21 years so the
audience can expect to see the exact
same performance from all the girls
um just with you know the new guidelines
and everything we're hoping that the
audience doesn't notice a difference or
they're just
even more impressed with our show than
they have been in the past you mentioned
real quick we have a few minutes seconds
left here when you got the call
that entertainment was returning and
essentially you were going back to work
uh where were you and what was your
first thought
yeah i was actually on the couch and it
was uh the day before my birthday
they got the call that we were going
back to work so it was literally the
best birthday present i could have ever
wished for to finally get back on stage
it was you know and then i got to you
know text all the casts and tell them
everyone they were coming back and it
was just it was the best day
we've been dying to go back on stage so
it's exciting well mariah for you and
the other entertainers up and down the
las vegas strip we're all excited for
you as well so good luck tonight
getting back on stage thank you very
much for joining us this morning and
happy birthday
belatedly thank you so much thank you
all right thank you
so let's look at some of the other
entertainment returning to mgm resorts
properties tonight
reopening we're talking about the
australian bee gees
brad garrett's comedy club opens carrot
tops performing david copperfield
we mentioned fantasy of course the
jabberwockies and thunder from down
under
all back in action tonight uh we have
also profiled earlier the entertainment
at caesars was a week or so ago i
believe it was so
things are starting to happen once again
guys on the las vegas strip and it's a
it's a good sign to see they've made the
changes necessary
to uh entertain but do it safely yeah so
exciting the show is still going to be
great too
fantasy that looks beautiful imagine
just like she said
she was on her couch you know and i
having we've all talked to people that
have been going through this
in las vegas and when you get the call
that you know things are opening back up
again that's uh it's quite a birthday
present
they've been on the sidelines for a long
long time so you know they're
itching ready to get back there and and
do what they do and do it well
and it's not just the on stage
performers it's all the folks who are
associated with the show too
the wardrobe dressers the ushers the
ticket takers
the folks who maintain the theater so
yeah it's it's a big deal
yeah the tech staff absolutely so good
luck to everybody getting back on stage
it is